Virginia boys among the latest victims
of the deadly flu epidemic seven year
old Kevin Baines died on Sunday just a
day after his flu diagnosis the CDC
projects roughly 700,000 flu-related
hospitalizations a season Manuel
Bojorquez is at Grady Memorial Hospital
that's in Atlanta which is struggling to
accommodate all the flu patients man
well good morning good morning this is
actually a mobile hospital it was built
primarily for disasters but even Grady
Memorial Georgia's largest hospital is
having to use it to keep up with the flu
outbreak you just loved everybody he was
a very loving kid that's how Samantha
and Kevin Baines described their son
Kevin they say the seven-year-old began
feeling sick on Friday and he just
doesn't wasn't getting any better so he
took them to the granny er they say
doctors in Gretna Virginia diagnosed
Kevin with the flu and strep throat and
sent him home with antibiotics on Sunday
morning his family woke up and found him
unresponsive a medical examiner is
determining Kevin's exact cause of death
the flu would make at Virginia's first
pediatric death from the virus this year
at least 19 states have reported at
least one pediatric death related to the
virus
this season children are just a fraction
of the thousands of flu patients
inundating hospitals nationwide
Atlanta's Grady Hospital has seen as
much as a 25 percent increase in overall
emergency room visits so far this year
Grady's chief of emergency medicine
doctor honey Atala
says the hospital called on a mobile
emergency department at base nearly 250
miles away to help tackle the increasing
patient demand at 500 plus patients a
day you physically just need the space
to put a patient in this is going to
help solve that Carolina's health care
system which owns the mobile hospital
expects it will be here for at least the
next 30 days doctors will begin using it
later today gale man well thank you